biden's preferential treatment for
illegals it's gotten worse because
according to florida congresswoman kat
kamik new photos inside a migrant
facility this one in mcallen texas look
at that pallets and pallets of baby
formula for illegal immigrants and their
families even as hard-working american
families we're now suffering a massive
uh a nationwide formula shortage we
reached out to the white house and the
department of homeland security for
comment yet to hear back here with
reaction florida congresswoman kat kamik
is with us uh wow um i know people
parents they cannot get the formula they
desperately need
now i'm not against helping out families
but they're not enforcing the law these
are not people that respected our
borders our laws and our sovereignty
why wouldn't all the pallets go to
american families first
well you know sean that's the crazy
thing just how insane everything is
right now that we're even having this
discussion but it points to what a total
dumpster fire the biden administration
truly is
look the bide administration is
responsible for this formula shortage
you know back in november their own fda
shut the number one manufacturer baby
formula down on a tip with no plan to
backfill the 43 percent that this
manufacturer is a part of the market
share so again typical by administration
no plan no contingencies no
way to backfill 43
of our nation's supply of baby formula
yet just today i'm getting word from
border patrol agents that there is a
tractor trailer full of pallets of baby
formula sitting in that store room come
on now this is exactly what america last
looks like you've got parents panicking
kids getting sick and the humanitarian
mission at the border the agents are
doing the best job that they can but man
their hands are tied
and and jenn sockey says i'll go ask
your doctor how to do it what is the
what is the doctor going to produce the
the baby formula what's fascinating is
you post this on facebook
and then you go to your district in
florida and you show empty shells where
baby formula is supposed to be
and they're all empty so there's so we
don't have any
but illegal immigrants are getting a top
priority now we also give preferential
treatment they don't have covert tests
because they're not going to be here
very long we're told they don't have
vaccine mandates they get free
transportation and my favorite is every
illegal immigrant is getting a biden
phone bought and paid for by the united
states taxpayer
that's a hundred percent again america
last that is what the biden
administration is all about and you know
you said that the dhs headquarters
hadn't got back to you with a comment i
heard tonight that they have prohibited
rank-and-file border patrol agents from
going into those store rooms because
they're panicked that we have exposed
this america last agenda this has to
stop we need to put our kids first and
this has to end biden's got to go
november's coming all right
congresswoman good job thank you for
sharing that with us hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else